made
but all these techniques i was okay it's
my turn to do the technique so already
i've said that i'm going to win this
technique
now my teaching is on 360 if not
a lot further over the years and how i
think about things
but let's say you're going to do sean
lucci
i get out of the way and i've got my
hand on it
i can do lots of techniques because
they're
an armed length
let's say you grab it
and
i can move over here i can do this so i
can move about
it earlier i can move around
so 200 films gonna talk about
what's he gonna do now
you know yes he could stand on my foot
he could butt me with his buttocks to
get another tummy that he's trapped
so what she's got if i say to you can
you escape it's his head's going to be
going around like a you know a marble in
a can going on
what can i think of
so i mean
so he's
he's gonna be quite desperate internally
thinking
i don't know i'm getting out of this are
you thinking that or not
pretty much yeah that seems likely
that's right
so my turn on the film
what i've decided to keep to myself for
many many years
i would
tell you
how to escape it
but it might take the rest of your life
because i'm still working on it might
take the rest of your life
to actually realize
you're not doing it 99 percent of your
like you don't time
because 99 percent of you like don't
tell me
oh it blocks me here sensei what do i do
i can't get this but you see you're
having all this freedom
you have time to think you're trying to
you've got to be here or at this point
it's difficult or when i get its hand
here is it right or should i be here so
i mean you've got all these things but
from here
you know
from here here's my thing you know i
don't know how to escape this one
so the answer i should be giving
of most sales pictures
the advertisement giving is
learn this
understand this
and you'll know the
you will have the secret trigger down
because you'll have a secret to what
you've been doing wrong
all you like in her career whether it's
a month or whether it's 30 years or 40
years
until you learn the answer
to that
you're not really doing like you don't
you're winning
and you're winning by
sheer freedom
but you didn't realize that you had
that in a bear hug
you ain't got no feeling
and i'm not going to show you how to do
it
i just want you to make it on the camera
because it will go with the
with the talking piece
all right because there's quite a bit to
understand about it
but but at least if i instill that to
you
if i instill that small piece into your
minds
to think
i've thought about that yeah
come on does it get harder well it does
get harder
you know
but uh it also gets a few more beautiful
because you start discovering
what your mind and your body can
actually do
but you don't even know it can do now
and that's like pandora's box you know
once you've found that you go wow
i've had all that freedom and i thought
that was so difficult
and
yet this is difficult
my ego can't find my way out of it
i perhaps can stand on their foot what's
where's their foot where is it
perhaps i can bit them
a big strong person
let's say nigel but eddie um
i'm wendy because she's powerful
i could feel that power when i done it
wrong
all right so i hope you've had a good
night i have and um
oh